[MUSIC]
One of the most common themes
in my work as an executive
coach is what I'd call essentially,
people problems.
Almost all my clients are CEOs,
the vast majority of them
are leaders of some group of people.
And the dilemma that they face,
if they want to work with me on this,
is the difficulties that
they're experiencing.
In some cases with the people they lead
and manage, in other cases with their
peers, in other cases with investors or
other stakeholders or authority figures.
And in that work,
I'm reminded of a great line from the
eminent French film director, Jean Renoir.
And he says, the hell of life is
that everyone has their reasons.
And that's really important to remind
ourselves that when we are met with
somebody whose behavior we find
frustrating or maddening or confusing,
we often lead to some assumptions,
we assume that they lack understanding.
We assume that that they're acting
out of spider capriciousness.
We make a whole host of assumptions,
which often justify our own perspective.
And are typically very unempathetic, and
what we fail to do habitually is stop and
ask ourselves,
what is that person's reason?
I find their behavior maddening or
frustrating,
they're getting in the way at somehow.
And what we need to do is slow
ourselves down and remind ourselves,
everyone has their reasons.
Very rarely in life, do we encounter
an actual social [INAUDIBLE],
they're very rarely doing out or somebody
who's deliberately going out of their way
to screw things up and
make things difficult for us.
It's much more often the case,
almost universally the case,
that would we find ourselves in conflict,
it's about misunderstandings, and
missed expectations, and
incorrect assumptions.
And so much of my work entails
encouraging people to slow down,
examine the assumptions that they're
making about the other person,
develop a theory of mind,
what is governing this other person?
What are their beliefs and assumptions?
What are their goals?
And can I allow that information
to inform how I approach them?
So rather than assuming,
they're taking these steps and
actions to kind of mess me up and
get in my way.
Can I take a broader perspective
on what might be driving them?
What impulses or reasoning might
be informing their behavior?
It's also important to bear in mind that
in some sense, all behavior is adaptive.
And so when we run into behavior that
we find frustrating or confusing,
it's important to ask ourselves,
well, what are they adapting to?
And for a leader, it's especially
important to ask, are they adapting to me?
Am I in some sense creating a condition
that they're finding the need to adapt to
that I might find frustrating?
So is there something I can do
to change how I'm showing up and
influence the environment in which
this other person is operating?
[MUSIC]